Our perspective on the world around us is very much about our vision
But how do you know if you really see it?
Can you really trust your eyes?
For example, these two rectangles are gray
Each has a distinctive gray color.
Or are they really?
They seem to be exactly alike
Even after you know there is a trick, your eyes refuse to see them as identical.
The color input causes the same result
I swear no scams or modifications have been applied
Fact, if you look at (they are white paint) munker-white illusion
You will find many examples
Check them through Photoshop and you'll see that the colors are exactly the same
A similar effect can be seen in this chessboard
Box A appears to be significantly darker than B
But you know more now, right?
Though your eyes can not see it
You know that when the surrounding image is removed
The two blocks will be the same color
So, what's going on here?
The fact that scientists do not fully understand this phenomenon
There are many complex biological factors
And nerve agents occur during it
At the end, our brain governs the colors and brightness by contrast
In other words, our brain compares the environment in an attempt to create our perspective
The goal of our senses or in this case our eyes
Not providing us with absolute physical colors or physical properties of our external reality
But explain what we see as effectively as possible
In order to interact with our environment in the most appropriate way
The trick of the box takes advantage of this phenomenon
Our brain knows that shadows make things seem darker
As a result, the brain balances by making the box appear lighter than it is
Until we shave the shadow out
Perhaps the most obvious examples of this gradient
Simply strip the middle of one color
They were removed in the background and it would seem obvious
Again, dark background effect on our perspective of the color of the tape
Relative perspective
So, do you still trust your eyes ?!
Have a question and you want to answer?
Ask him in comments or on Facebook and Twitter
Subscribe to more weekly scientific videos :)